well I talked to Tiffany l'aigle moving
she said that you all were working on
something else while you were shooting
this movie can I just show it's about
three beautiful women I have bomb-ass
person we even have a theme song already
so we just need a punch all to tell me
about purses and the thieves all well
it's a I mean you've got it you've got
to buy it to really hear this story
business create the t3 exciting women
and they have purse that's beautiful
beautiful handbags of all sorts and who
knows what's in it yeah some weapons do
you don't know it might be cosmetics and
maybe it's just basically just going
there's like a posing with purses first
and it it may have if we were doing it a
lot probably at a certain point andrea
was like I'd love to get through scene
without you posing and all saying purses
but I have I guess I'll guess I'll come
public with it I can't hold I can't hold
a purse on my shoulder I'm not able for
real not able and built like a Christmas
tree so my shoulders go down and just
this part it's built like your Christmas
tree um and I I cannot I can't keep a
handbag with a strap on my shoulder it
falls off constantly so we'd be the
middle of seeing them like this how it's
gonna go I'm so sorry taping it and
tried sewing it to my shirt like at one
point I did a crossbody tried but the
70s purse is shorter so then it becomes
kind of a bit of a mood sling so the
amount of takes I ruined dealing with
purses and then we were like this fall
purses so when you tried to be a
gangster with those 70 persons
it was a situation it's a real situation
I think that male gangsters don't have
to deal with that's true that's true
which one of you three is the real
gangster Wow don't mess so much so fast
yeah Joe is that real - I mean I would I
wouldn't say that I'm a gangsta
entrepreneur what was it like doing a
movie like this with three ladies in
very traditionally male roles but it was
so plausible and the way you all brought
me oh for sure I mean I think I think I
mean I think we all gravitate to the
script for the same reason it all felt
real these were three very different
characters but they all were in a
similar circumstance of being under
about undervalue they had no power it
was more of a power struggle so I don't
think it was that this story is about
women versus men I just think I loved it
because it was watching these three
characters come into it at the base of
it and you saw them make a decision when
they're forced into a corner do it come
out fighting or do I do I roll over and
just take it and to watch these three
women come back and and in demand their
power and their place is what I think
made it so interesting we wanted to know
at any time with the 70s close did you
choose your 70s close or how did you
choose how did you make the decisions
about your seventies gear because
sometimes 70s clothes can be horrifying
let's just be honest having lived
through the 70s and looked at some
seersucker pants I've worn it scares me
like I'm like days
give me a height a high waist something
tucked in and a big bell oh my god and
then you just wear pantyhose and slips
and he was spanked you always had
pantyhose over oh you know what it's a
working pantyhose back
when I was a kid learn how to make
pantyhose so that I can fix the runs
into myself really yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]